this is the trending tab visualized
there are over 40,000 videos here with
over 2,000 unique channels all
represented on this graph here all of
that and more will be explained right
now I'm trying to learn how to go
trending from this video I'm trying to
understand what does YouTube want from
from us s created a clip from the show
the view that has 10,000 views is not
trending but it's number three trend
that's when you start to think oh this
is real I want to show you a clip from
the trending town and as you can see a
lot of the videos don't seem to be made
by creators
[Music]
the Trini tap is the most talked about
least understood part of YouTube and
part of that's because for a long time
we've had nothing but anecdote and
speculation but today I'm hoping that
changes because for the last few months
I've been analyzing a data set that
covers seven months of trending history
for November 2017 to June 2018 now if
you want to know about the person who
created the data set and Mitchell jolly
if you wanted to know how I analyze the
data set I know a lot of you don't care
so we're gonna just put it in a second
video but for now we're just gonna talk
about the results I'm gonna catch you up
to speed with how we got to that first
intro shot and we're gonna do it really
quickly so we start with a huge amount
of data 40,000 entries a lot of my
reason for doing this is I want to
answer the age-old question is YouTube
biased towards traditional media so if
we're gonna answer this question we have
to classify all the channels that trend
and find out if their traditional media
or not I had to make some definitions of
my own here for the types of channels
that our traditional media versus what
is a youtuber or independent creator and
I made a few other classifications as
well and now all we have to do is figure
out which of these two thousand channels
is which manual classification like this
would take way too long for one person
so I enlisted 70 people from my second
channel in order to help me crowdsource
this data classification and when that's
all finished you get this so this is
what we get how do we read it so the
first thing is is the color key blue
will be traditional media orange is
commercial green is movies trailers
video games red is music purple is
youtuber and brown is conventional viral
anyone who trended with less than 10,000
subscribers so what do we get all right
so the y-axis is the average view count
they got before they got on training so
as soon as we got we see them on
trending how many views do they have
when that happens so we can think of
that as sort of the barrier to them
getting on training how many views they
needed to get on trending and then we
have the number of unique trending
videos so let's do a for instance let's
say you have I don't know Lele pons she
seems to have trended about 10 times on
the training tab and she it took her
about four million views on average to
get on trending goes ten times okay so
that's how to read this so what do we
find
well the data is pretty clear number one
if you are high up on this you're not
going to be trending a lot the chances
are you don't we don't see you trend a
lot and that sort of makes intuitive
sense if it takes you a lot of views to
trend you're a lot less likely to trend
a lot because it's very hard to get
those views now who do we find trending
a lot who do we find with a lot of times
on trending the answer is overwhelmingly
traditional media traditional media as
in ESPN as in The Ellen Show Jimmy
Fallon Jimmy Kimmel Stephen Colbert
Netflix MBA a CNN box almost all late
night or like traditional meat like the
most mainstream of mainstream media is
who we see over represented on trending
over and over and over again
and I want to stress this is not due to
the fact they're getting more views than
these other youtubers are for example if
Logan Paul's barrier to trending is
about 11 million views then no matter
how much he uploads he's a lot less
likely to trend frequently didn't
someone like ESPN whose barrier to
trending is on average about 500,000
views but that's not all though
something else caught my eye Beauty by
his trending data is super interesting
because he trends all over the world yet
he barely trends in the u.s. now here's
where I tell you that we don't just have
the US dataset we have all these other
countries too and when you look at those
countries PewDiePie is crushing it
everywhere except the us even in
non-english speaking countries if this
is a simple algorithm it's bizarre that
the US would be the one place he does so
poorly now YouTube has mentioned for
some time that they have human
moderators perhaps he gets blocked most
of the time but how do you test that I
decided to look at other controversial
creators to see how they fared on the
training cap in the United States many
of these are us-based channels so if
they did poorly in the US but not in
other countries it'd be evidence of
perhaps some suppression in the US I
decided to compare the training rates in
the u.s. with Canada this is because
Canada is operating in the same time
zones they have similar cultural
interests and they also speak English
now all of these controversial creators
are extremely popular and have some
level of swearing or edginess to them
and this is what I found on the US side
many of these creators aren't trending
at all or if they are trending it's once
or twice and that's it for comparison
here's the Canadian side of things so
this is just an insane difference it's
night and day I mean people like Joe
Rogan are trending zero times in America
and they're turning a hundred times in
Canada even though Joe Rogan is American
based people like h3 are trending maybe
60 times in Canada one time in the
United States
Philip DeFranco is turning two times in
the United States he's trending 87 times
in Canada and I know you're thinking
well maybe Canada's just totally a
different beast even though we did
expect it to be pretty similar well if
we look at the top 12 channels who
trended in America we actually don't see
that we see what we'd expect relatively
similar trending numbers so Canada being
slightly different does not explain why
these controversial creators for doing
so poorly the only thing that makes up
for it is maybe the idea that America
had moderation at this point in Canada
had a lot less moderation so these
controversial channels were freed to
trend so he may have unwittingly gotten
an accurate view of how much some of
these youtubers would be trending if it
weren't for human intervention now I
have to remind you here that that's a
theory but we haven't even gotten to the
worst part which is the double standard
YouTube seems to have for what is banned
on the trending tab for youtubers and
traditional media like maybe I can
understand that you want to show
family-friendly content but why is
late-night comedy always allowed and
considered appropriate while these
creators aren't late-night swears too
and even though they bleep out some of
it they keep other parts like why is
this okay and these bleeps are my own by
the way loaded trending top grabbed by
the printing top you downing Tubbs I
moved on her like a venom cup but I
couldn't get there hear Jimmy Kimmel go
rap your blending talk around your neck
and choke yourself to death
I've also heard like their go-to is just
will you cuss and I'm like so does
everybody else
like they trended a song that was like
controversial about like the roles and
Carnaby wasn't it then you play it at
the way I've been best UK they trended I
don't it feels very personal to me which
is why I hear like pick and choose who
the rules apply to the rules apply to
some people and the rules do not apply
to other people you guys are pushing
already established filmmakers and
letting them do whatever they want how
about you promote and help up-and-coming
filmmakers are made on your platform
yeah I think that point by the raka raka
guides really encapsulates how a lot of
creators are feeling right now that
they're feeling disenfranchised by the
platform that they helped build and they
feel like it's unfair and there's
certainly a lot of evidence to support
that finally the last thing I noticed
was just how news was treated on YouTube
so there's a thing called category ID in
our data set
categories include entertainment
education and even news and I got
curious when I saw CNN box in the
Washington Post doing so well on
trending so I started to think how much
of news on the trending tab is
mainstream news versus alternative news
and I mean alternative in the sense of
independent not in terms of their
politics so to find out I filtered our
data set by news and graphed it the same
way we did our last video and this is
what we find 95% of all news takes on
trending is traditional media that's
ridiculously unfair to anyone seriously
trying to do news right now
independently philip defranco for
example is one of the few youtubers who
even appeared on trending and it took
him one point four million views on
average to appear those two times on
trending in comparison The Associated
Press trended seven times and how many
views did it take them to appear in
trending 10,000 this is just a different
bar and standard for independent
creators if there is a standard to which
we all should be set to it should be an
equal one and look before we move on I
know YouTube has sort of made in creator
memo they've said oh we're gonna fix all
this we're gonna you know bump up the
creator ratio to at least 50% and all
I'll say is that it's not about
percentages it's about a level playing
field and what
mean by that is look what's unfair and
all of this has nothing to do with an
extra creator here or there making it to
trending what's unfair is that YouTube
has clearly put their hands on the
levers to make it literally easier for
traditional media to get on trending
what's unfair is that controversial
youtubers get held to a different
standard than traditional media and that
95% of news on trending on YouTube is
all mainstream takes so while I think
YouTube is right in taking the first
steps in fixing the system it's about
more than fixing a simple ratio it's
about giving the creators who build this
platform a fair chance I'm trying to
understand what does YouTube want what
what does YouTube want what would that's
when you start to think oh this is a
real
[Music]
and as you can see a lot of the videos
don't seem to be made by creators Oh
[Music]
wrap your funding up around your neck
with yourself - yeah it's not real
thank you so much for watching that
video the last thing I want to say is
sort of to answer an objection that I
know I'd have while watching this video
if I didn't do the research myself and
it's along the lines of a realization
that I had while researching this video
and it shaped the way I made it which is
that if you're a savvy viewer you
probably noticed I only checked out the
relationship with views and trimming and
you might be saying well don't you know
Stephen that the training algorithm
considers us any number of signals
there's a lot more signals that YouTube
considers why didn't you consider any of
those why don't you try to figure out
what those had to do with it and I'll
say a few things there number one I
actually did try I looked at things like
likes dislikes comments I scraped for
subscriber counts I checked out the
median view count of someone's channel
versus the performance of their trending
video and tried to see is there
relationship there and the answer is
that there's not none of those are the
Silver Bullet - what we might call trend
ability and my revelation sort of about
black boxes and if you don't know what
black box is something where you have
input you have some something that
nobody really quite understands an
algorithm most of the time and you have
some kind of output what I realized was
rather than focusing on the algorithm
which contains signals that we do not
have access to such as shares where the
views are coming from what views YouTube
is even considering outside of YouTube
itself we don't have access to any of
that back-end data so we literally don't
have access to some of the key variables
so when that's the case instead of
trying to deconstruct this we can look
at this we can look at what the output
is because we know the input
and if we have the we have the algorithm
we sort of have the output but it's also
the case that if you have the output and
the input you can make inference as to
what the algorithm the black box is and
that's what this video is all about so
my intention when only talking about
views was to shift the conversation away
from this and to talk about this because
this is in the end what actually matters
when you're talking about a systemic
bias regardless of whether there's
explicit or implicit biases here whether
human moderation or just YouTube's
choices and what they favor traditional
media is getting the bulk of the
attention you might say they have a
different standard for them and that is
what I wanted to highlight in this video
so I know I didn't get to everything I
know I didn't cover YouTube's own
intentions I know I didn't talk about
every angle of this is not the end-all
be-all take on the training tab but I
wanted to give you a little insight into
why I focused on this side of things so
thank you so much for watching thank you
to my patrons everyone who's Forsman
patreon it's a huge part of this channel
and I hope you have a wonderful day
check out that second video if you want
to see the nuts and bolts and I'll see
you later
[Music]